joachim mänert get out of the subways
berlin south cross station his face was
immediately recognized by cameras the
former police officer accused of control
room that takes the crowd special
recognition protesting supplemented technology
before the face recognition is
the monster
here it is about testing
technologies tracking & security in
football having to store more day of
respectable people learning the new
technology must be installed es zu nass
password protection argument that my
saying is data protection system as well as
increasing terrorism face recognition
face recognition is coming to germany